okay for people joining this livestream
this is the first of I think six of
these for today um and four things that
we are preparing for the next version
wolfing language so first we have a look
at this should be the last look at this
RDF and sparkle package now the
documentation are we calling it graft
store is that B is that what we are
referring to it as
Mia that was named you proposed as a
term for that contains rdf and sparkle
and potentially in the future other
graph related things do you think it
makes sense I'm okay with it I don't
have a better idea because it's not just
for EF or just Sparta it's a container
for both of these things great
documentation search does not work and
whoever's project managing please report
that where is this hanging off is this
hanging off here for example
by the way also this is almost
unreadable alight another thing to
report please who's who is whose project
managing here okay can you respond them
okay so that's okay all right um so now
where is this gonna go from the route
guide page we haven't done that knitting
yet right no this dystopian okay
oops well that this this page isn't this
isn't correctly set up yet
okay well that's that that's a separate
thing to be to be thought about um it
would help to know where that's getting
knitted in because that would help us
understand where the graph store is the
right name to this um I guess then the
media question a little bit do we
consider this to be a pre version of the
future fully integrated one or is it a
self-contained outside one surfing an
existing stumbled the latter okay in my
opinion
some reason that oh yeah got lighter
that doesn't work right now Andrea you
saw that right okay the pulldown is
darker there venters there
do we have do we have a precedent for
linking from system functions to non
system functions but but there wouldn't
it be they're not is a subpart or four
spot on the external interfaces and
connections to the right of databases
well here so this is yeah this is right
this is good this is by the way
obviously that the stuff with the
database integration needs to get on to
this page right I think there's a
meeting after this yeah
yes but Stephen let's not forget that
currently this is about the database
link mostly I'm well aware I'm well
aware obviously this has to have at the
top the new stuff and then it will be
followed by some of these connectivity
things right yeah so I suspect this is a
page that this has to go onto and maybe
it's just a seal so from the knowledge
representation page although that seems
a shame for the graph store stuff all
right let's go look at the graph store
stuff now
you
you
that's not how we typically would do
this first of all that's the wrong font
there right that should be italicized
who is looking into it
why do we do I usually have a thing
called RDF concepts it's not usually the
type of thing that we'd have on a guide
page right what a sparkle update what
the heck is that there's an update
language to update okay that's not the
right title for a guide page at all
Michael you're aware of this no it's not
well it's committee or the wrong name
okay okay okay fine so you didn't have
but I mean you you are aware that it is
wrong but you haven't looked at it it's
the boys okay fine fine that's good
that's that's that's perfectly okay so
it just needs to be
no I mean it these are action type
things at the top
you
okay so why doesn't this say I don't
know Stan why this doesn't say graph
store package symbol that's how those
who usually are set up what happened -
it's it's s it it all experimental I I
know but that's wrong
like for example if I go look at um
Andrea this is this is for you to deal
with I mean that this is if I go look at
this oh wow well it doesn't look the way
I thought it looked
now maybe it's okay maybe it says this
alright okay
hmm I could do it a little bit less
space there I think all right fair
enough
why doesn't this have a.m. that should
have Andrea that's missing its self yeah
this is missing also on this page
that's why spider will show up
boy there's a lot of detail here okay
so is this what we're doing we're
repeating the needs graph store in the
documentation each example group needs
its own needy safe containing scoped
yeah you know it's always a bad sign
when the basic examples involve you know
15 lines of code
but I guess it is what it is is this
really what you want to do here with all
of this detail with these that having to
define these functions even in a basic
example we could also have a query
string example as opposed to symbolic
but there's one of this examples we are
well it's long it's extremely bipolar
and repetitive yeah okay so you claim
the cognitive length is not large
exactly well I don't entirely disagree
about that
okay
that has been renamed now to already
have store so instead of an RTF data set
and an RDF graph they have no an RDF
store
represents an typo yes okay there's a
lot of work here
just so long as it's not a recipe for
turtle soup no this would be included Oh
what the to the table
okay
what is this so there I defined his
namespaces two times in two different
ways because for the letter comparison
of symbolic queries versus string
queries
sorry what's that what's the point of
seeing this don't name spaces I I used
them later inquiries the first law oh I
see I see Justin just in this example
file yes well you know this kind of
suggests to me
you
you know is it the case that our
external reference mechanism
is this related to our external
reference mechanism should it be so you
don't have to define these all or are
these reasons things those are short
hands for our ice island issue is that
those prefixes are not really
standardized they're just convention
that means it's not really easy to come
up with some way to define them by
default sorry I mean are these
particular IR is something particularly
notable or not yes like the RDF and are
there schema well so why are we doing
this as a repeated top-level code if
everybody's gonna need them why don't we
have a built in my ever accessing them
we could do that for a limited number
for ones that are very well known
you
would we put them into a deeper context
like graft or bhakti no no no we would
have a function that is like external
reference right that just names these
things with string names of some kind so
what you can say is for example I don't
know whether this is the right thing but
you know like we have external reference
well which we don't have yet but but
this thing here could be you know I
don't like that color
what's an identifier not reference okay
which we also don't have but that was
that's the name right so would it make
sense to have something like this where
we have a you know the the category of
thing and then whatever that the payload
is there yes something like this we
could have we could have some default
prefixes so we would have to review
which ones are used commonly and how may
be a mechanism for you so to introduce
new ones fine well I mean the mechanism
I believe an external identifier yes I
mean that's a different issue
introducing new ones but at least for us
we can curate some set of these yes and
I think for RDF ada might be a list of
default namespaces or prefix but I have
to look into it okay
all right so does this is this
consistent your understanding Allen that
this would be a reasonable thing to use
external identifier for yes this is what
we had we had talked about before some
some of these things would definitely be
sensible built-in things that we have
some string to represent the prefix okay
okay
so what are we looking at here I have to
run this welder
has been renamed or they've stored now
why didn't that I don't know I wasn't
able to edit this is this what is that
thing what is going on here what is this
won't you copy pasted the students yes
that was copy and paste it okay so
that's why I can't edit it um so is this
gonna work or is this not okay with this
audience
Langstrom yes have renamed and already
to RF string your adventure this
disaster okay so what are we looking at
in this meeting man
so in this meeting I like to review
quickly the names if you spend anything
weird like and and therefore to look at
the swee guide pages they list all the
names that are introduced like maybe
start with RTF concept or sparkle query
those are the basic building blocks to
that we need to represent RDF data
what is a shorthand what does that mean
it means that RDF has its own mechanism
for representing lists as linked lists
and it is very verbose to write that
sound clear shorthand or just say
represents to say what it represents I
don't know what a shorthand mean
you
I I don't even know what this I don't
know what this means
collection of the EEI using RDF
collection vocabulary what does that
mean
so these items are represent as a linked
list in the graph using audio first and
out of rest and RF note and you can
write it manually but yeah it's it's
difficult so when you use that instead
the sort of collection instead it is
expanded to dead representation
so you guys got the right name I
understand what that what why should it
be called the audience collection it's
the technical term for that from the
start so you could evaluate the basic
example and then do first of the order
of store to see what that expands to but
it's a complicated thing
you
whatever what that was so first of this
the heck is that well it seems like Hugh
UID is broken in that built but it's not
a crash disposal or a door okay okay so
what am I supposed to see here so so you
see how this linked list is represented
using multiple triples you say they are
there first another first so to not make
the use of write that out every time
they talk about lists we introduce the
order of collection
well it's inspired by sparkle and turtle
syntax it's basically the same
understand what this means at all and I
don't my it's not in a sub list here he
could put it in a sub list yes
but is it in fact the the equivalent of
a list of things that just doesn't
happen to be represented by a linked
list
no it's it expands to a linked list I
understand that but I'm asking you this
is a way of doing it without explicitly
representing it as a linked list is that
right if I understand it right yes it's
because there's no list data type in RDF
right should I go and edit these pages
or what how should we be doing this
oh I'm not able to edit these pages
because it doesn't get set up correctly
as that right yes it's in it then I
can't edit these pages so I'm telling
you that should be reworded to be
something like you know represents a
list like collection of the RDF entities
or whatever you call it
Issa by
friend functions this this does not help
me this is just confusing right
yes okay so let's keep going here so
you
you
I don't know why that isn't called type
here but anyway and why does this what
are the possible types it doesn't say so
in principle a user can introduce their
own type and defining what it means and
then applications are free to interpret
it or not in some basic from basic types
from XML schema are automatically
supported so like dates numbers are
automatically converted to form language
forms no solid should be saying that in
the documentation yes I can give
examples
you
you
what does that that's not the right way
usually we give a description okay
line-based format yes in the sense that
you can read line by line and get one
travel out I see
okay fair enough
okay
oops
we don't have any seal sauce on this
page how come
all right that should have cos øz so
that I could get to these other pages
yes
I mean this should be probably
I don't know what it should say but RDF
concept is not a possible name for one
of these pages basic RDF structures or
something a concept is not something
that makes any sense when you have a
concrete set of you know things that
you're going to yes
I don't know how how does this reference
the rdf page
you
did you understand what I'm asking yeah
also BSC also know it probably should be
something which is a link from this page
because we probably should have okay so
is this the main page about Sparkle or
not where is the main page about Sparkle
yes so spa crested divided in reading
and writing and reading is the spark
very okay and that's not going to work
how do you think that's going to link to
the front page to our
you
um we need one meta page in between yes
we need one page it's about Sparkle and
RDF and so on
that's a top-level page that just
basically is about support for you know
something about graph stores right it's
a basic graph store page which points to
both the sparkle query Sparkle um and
this should be called something like you
know querying graph stores using sparkle
or some such other thing something like
that makes sense yes
and then this one should be called
probably updating or let's see writing
to something like that writing to graph
stores using sparkle yes
you
I have no clue what something like that
does that's the data from the graph
identified by
isn't that the wrong way round shouldn't
it be the thing that it's being added to
first and the things being added second
you
I think think that's how all these
functions work
that's the existing one and that's the
new one right
either yes that's the way around it
should surely work just like assignments
etc
now I guess this is like copy file here
so I suppose this way around is right
yes it's like copy file
you
how can it o is an operator these that
this so this one is an operator but
these are not operators why is it this
an operator they are all operators but
but does this get applied to something
yes first you have imported store and
then you apply this operator to the
store
you
you
you
so all Sparkle query and update
functions are operators
you
I I have you know I have no idea how
this
I I can't comment on any of this I mean
this is really I sure hope this is going
to get used
I I don't know I also think by the way
that using the slash slash notation is
really obscure for these in these cases
I think you'll be much better if you
said Sparkle load open bracket country
store yes I don't know this doesn't even
work
that's not even correct right doesn't
slash slash have lower binding than
equal sign
I believe it does Devon is correct
no just okay
you
oh yeah I trait has to work um okay
you
okay so
this is applying Sparkle select two
is this does this one
this mrs. Wilson branch or something yes
that works statue broken master why does
it say future because it's not optimized
well enough to
people to start using it okay and where
does it actually run its evaluating the
queries on the client site so it has to
load in the whole entity store for
isotopes it's trying to load as minimal
data as possible but are we ultimately
going to expose everything through a
sparkle and point of our own the could
maybe do that but we haven't
investigated yet so but it might be nice
to define IR Icefall our entities and
properties yes it probably would be
although I mean
why not accept that that does that imply
that I mean the fact we have IR eyes
doesn't necessarily imply that that
anybody can access them right not
necessarily first of all these guys can
just stand for themselves but it's
usually helpful if they redirect to
something or if they show some
information or find for the girl and
then one idea is that when you enter the
entity in entity syntax in war from
alpha you get information about it so
this would be a candidate nice IRI
and today's sentence what do you mean by
entity syntax if you enter in Wolfram
Alpha entity square bracket I see
something you could yeah um okay so this
is working right for an instance yes
really does that work using this
integration system yes
but I I can't keep up with database
things changing so I it's resting for
now until those things are more stable
what is this stuff you're showing here
those is a listing of all the sparkles
features and their corresponding
symbolic versus string representation
you
okay well what's the point here I mean
okay so it's just just translation table
so so cop you ibly there's some tutorial
it's necessary for people yes I'll go to
show that the symbolic version yes
so that means if a sparkle knowledgeable
people come and want to write a symbolic
version then they would need such a well
this very document that you have here
seems like a reasonable start yes and
Philip is working on some book flows
okay
what is this well that's what I actually
already did I think it's okay
alright so now the next thing for this
meeting was the discussion of existing
end points is that correct
yes you heard us for this deal okay so
this is so I just ran your um a data set
thing what is this
so what is this this is Aaron's thing
yeah yes
so this is
a big long list how is the sorted it's
sorted by the number of triples and but
this must be an approximation correct
any of them are
what was LOD a lot an aggregator of
things that are on here
okay
that's a protein database with 13
billion triples
you
we paired that way
well that one says site can't be reached
when I go to that European are these
URLs correct
Eurostat links statistics that URL says
it can't be reached yeah there are this
is not the most up-to-date or well
maintained data set that I imported here
the URL should be kept current but
aren't and it took some cleanup and
finish just to get it into this state
okay by the way when I imported this
here why is this showing in red
a copy pasted data set right that has
this stuff somehow because data set has
additional information that's not
documented so she took scholarly things
it doesn't belong there
the same four measures and many other
functions you know we should have a way
of handling these things that don't turn
them read the Turnham green thing and
these in cases like this um that that is
something for the user assistance
meeting if Andrea could bring it to user
assistance meeting that will be good yes
it departs okay okay now what's this
errand
okay this was taking from that list that
you were just looking at this was taking
everything that he has a sparkle end
point and I queried them for the number
of triples and these are how many were
successful the list you were just
looking at is somewhere around fifteen
hundred I believe RTF collections linked
data collections about five hundred of
them have Sparkle endpoints and you're
looking at a list of 101 that I was able
to get a successful query on and all I
was querying for was the number of
triples available at that end okay so
the other 400 failed in some way is that
correct that's correct
okay um it's not particularly impressive
with people keeping up their end points
but you know there is a lot of data
available to download and build your own
end point which is the criteria for
inclusion into this collection was not
that you have a live end point but that
you have RDF data available um
you
you
it's already hold on a second here so
what are we doing with these
what will we do with these is to not
seem to be that fantastical there's a
lot of there's a lot of noise and a lot
of weird things like the alpine skier
racers of Austria and such but there are
some things in there that are pretty
pretty nasty lot what's that something
people care in this part of the build
this one ski racers in Austria is
important for sure sure to Austrians yes
absolutely and buts are we going to try
and get these what what are we gonna do
what we trying to put these in the data
repository somehow or what that's being
discussed
Michael had brought that up as a
possibility I have to talk to Alan about
that and we could talk about what we
want to do with it we could just curate
a list of sparkle endpoints and they
have the endpoints themselves and not so
much the data I was more singing kind of
keeping an updated list of what's out
there so that people quickly know what
to import yeah this is really pretty
random stuff yeah it's all over the
place I'm one thing that was a
particular interest that I poked around
a bit is a DB nary DB n ary if you are
you'll be hitting their tune this is
sorted by tidal and that's a
multilingual translation what is the
lemming module what if the lemon model
the lemon model is a way of representing
word meanings and relationships across
different human languages
okay it's interesting um TVP dear in
Basque okay cool okay what are the ones
that are actually interesting here
I'm not sure I looked closely enough at
this list to make decisions about that
Aaron has just produced this list of
things that were actually functional
yeah that's kind of get to be determined
there's all of this this eagle-eye
program I don't know much about but it
seems to be linking biomedical research
from all kinds of different institutions
I'm off to buy those things might be of
endless but yeah there's a large
collection of bio things that are
available that don't have that are
sparkling points keep on timing out but
there's a huge the bottom on top on
Library of Congress has a sparkle end
point doesn't it they do not they supply
a RDF data for you to make your own
Sparkle end point the British National
Library has a sparkle end point okay so
what about these things where people are
doing that supplying RDF data is that
something where we should have some
graph stores in the data repository
because that a lot of times I think the
eyes of a lot of them is going to be
credited but isn't but to keep them
updated wouldn't it not really much
easier just have basically data set or
entity store awesome RDF resources out
there and then one thing is trust kind I
get the I are I enjoyed the whole thing
in possibly or alternatively have an
extra if they're ones that we think are
of persistent interest like the Library
of Congress one perhaps to have that be
part of this external identifier stuff
yes that sounds a bit more sane than
then loading in the hole or thinking
having it as a repository object right
well this document itself is quite
interesting
okay all right what else do we need to
make sure to cover um I think it was
amazing so we know we will improve the
guide pages and littered it fine and
then we need to figure out how we link
them up tier nine system all right
sounds good
okay um this is interesting this is
interesting you know so this is probably
a list a pretty close to complete list
of public Sparkle endpoints is that the
work that you'll believe it's I would
say half of them to to the majority of
them yeah because there's a lot of
obscure stuff out there but this is
stuff that made you know this is of the
big stuff yes I am reasonably confident
that this is a a okay yeah that's a very
handsome I'll say so I know the
partnerships group is dealing with some
people who are Sparkle ODF cetera
enthusiasts can you make sure that they
get a copy of this sure sure
okay sounds good complete next steps
after fixing the guide pages well I
think we're freezes tomorrow and we're
good to go
so far as I can see okay I had a few
comments there like that you know that
add you know the detection efficiency
there was low like 20% probably so I
think you know Michael I think should go
through these things one last time yeah
I mean this is a package and it's
experimental so you know it's not
absolutely cast in stone the damage is
limited right all right sounds good
wonderful it's very a lot of stuff here
okay see you later
Thanks